and joining us now with more on the
recovery efforts in the Lone Star State
is Texas lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
lieutenant governor thank you so much
for being with us tonight for the very
important story so please tell our
viewers where you think that things
stand right now tonight in terms of the
rescue and the recovery efforts well the
storm is shifted as you know it started
in Rockport and near Corpus and it's
moved across the state about 300 miles
so now that's why you have the most
current and most important rescue going
on in Beaumont as you just report that's
where the water is the heaviest but the
rescue continues in Houston it was a
wind damage storm in the West and has
become a flooding storm we have about
35,000 people in shelters we think about
one out of every ten people leave their
home or in shelters that means three or
four hundred thousand people have been
displaced there with friends or family
or somewhere else some got hotel space
and then we have 14,000 Guard troops
deployed so we have security and rescue
efforts going on and we have about 500
roads that are still closed but I want
to thank President Trump who has been on
this before the storm hit we've gotten
just tremendous cooperation and service
from FEMA and the president governor
Abbott is doing a great job in command
and I'll tell you what Kimberly we are
Texas tough and as the word from
literature once said the worst of times
and the best of times this is the worst
of times for many but the best of times
by seeing the quality of the American
volunteer coming from other states and
the quality of the volunteerism of
Texans you saw that first responder
swimming next to that horse his life a
danger to save a horse all these
volunteers we've had our own Dunkirk
flotilla come in to save thousands and
thousands of people will never get the
official count I've bet ten to fifteen
thousand people have been rescued many
by volunteers and our brave first
responders what else do you need tonight
in your state in terms of viewers
watching at home what is the best that
way for them to direct their efforts to
provide assistance or help for those in
need
first of all give to either redcross.org
or Samaritan's Purse the charities that
we know are here on the ground and there
are many others but those are two we
need a lot of money tymberlee many of
these people didn't have flood insurance
they've lost everything the only thing
they have is the backpack on their back
their kids don't have any clothes for
schools the kids have lost their toys
the parents have lost their cars they've
lost their furniture but they have their
lives what is remarkable Kimberly the
biggest disaster probably in the history
of America natural disaster and every
life is precious but right now there we
think somewhere around three dozen
people have lost their lives that's a
miracle that is a miracle but we need
prayers we need the financial help but
remember this Kimberly right now in a
time when much of America was divided
they're all focused and and helping
Texas and in Texas there are no
Republicans tonight and no Democrat no
black white and brown or moderates or
conservatives we are one Texas helping
each other
Texas tough we'll survive will prevail
and we will lead to show others how to
take on these types of the death
disasters as we learn from this as we've
learned from disasters in the past you
know certainly Texas really truly a
shining example to the rest of the
country of what we can do when we come
together like you said in President
Trump when he was there echoing those
same you know comments and sentiments
that you're sharing with our viewers
tonight in terms of coming together
there are those that that criticize and
questions the president's action saying
that he didn't show empathy enough or
that he should have gone down to hug
victims of the ravaged or Mary but that
also presents somewhat of a logistical
problem when you have someone coming in
like a president and shutting down areas
where relief is still so sorely needed
well I saw the president on Tuesday and
had a chance to visit with him with the
governor and with our two senators
Cornyn and Cruz and I can tell you this
we all think he played it pitch perfect
he didn't get in the way of first
responders he didn't take away from the
effort he came in to Corpus where things
had settled a little bit they still have
issues there but he inspired the people
he came here to say I'm leading on this
issue what I like about the president
he's a business guy and this is he looks
at this and says we have a problem
what do we need to get back in business
what do we need to get the X is up and
running and and fix it and and he has
been all in from the declaration that
came so quick as he said about 35
seconds before the storm really hit he
and governor Abbott were close together
and I'm proud of our president I'm proud
of what they're doing but make no
mistake as brock long from fema who's
doing a great job for us here we know
this is going to be a long recovery
we still have problems as a report
showed it will be weeks before many
people get in their home months before
others and a year or more before
everything is back to the new normal but
I'm grateful for everyone our local
officials our county judges our mayor's
you can't imagine Kimberly every day we
have a briefing at 8 a.m. you can't
imagine the long list that we have to go
down just like Beaumont now you know
we're gonna have to supply water for
every citizen that's bottled water that
has to be trucked in I was in Victoria
yesterday I think it was and Kent the
days are all one and they is of
yesterday we were shipping in bottles of
water for 80,000 people that's a massive
effort to get in under time it is it's a
tremendous operation we've been through
it before nothing like this but again it
was the worst of times in the best of
times and I'm so proud to be a Texan and
I'm so proud of all Americans outside of
Texas who decided they want to be a
Texan you know I always tell people when
I give a speech no one moves to Texas
Kimberly they arrive here and Texas
moves into them I want to say Santa and
they want to stay and they and they do
by the way absolutely and just imagine
that just you know when I think about it
the luxury water what we take for
granted you know every day just so you
can have clean drinking water for those
that are sick the elderly and firmb
anybody to just be able to have that to
be able to survive and also water
continuing to rise in some areas so this
is far from over but as you say Texas is
strong and I understand the president is
coming back to see you I understand he's
coming in Saturday and I believe he's
coming in to Houston and by the way our
prayers go out to our friends in
Louisiana and other states that are
experiencing a heavy rain now moving up
through Tennessee and in other areas you
know Kimberly it's a it is a difficult
time for so many and and people have to
go to their new normal of you know if
they move to if they were displaced
where their kids go to school how they
get their benefits if their senior
citizens their Social Security check all
of those things you know you have to get
back running at life but we'll do that
you know you can buy new stuff and you
can repair sheetrock and get new carpet
but you can't replace your life and
people I think are so grateful just to
be to be alive
and to be alive I was out with one of
those rescue trucks in a neighborhood
with high water the other day and no one
knew I was on the truck I'm just helping
the volunteers who were volunteers they
had this old army truck and a lady came
up to be in a neighborhood Kimberly that
was pretty desolate it was like a ghost
town
and we're looking for people who wanted
to get out and she came up and she
happened to recognize me
it was my old senate district where i
used to be a senator and she said if I'd
known you were coming I'd have made you
dinner mr. lieutenant governor very
sweet and I thought that's what a great
what a great spirit she had and I said
don't you want to get on the truck she
said no I rescue cats I've got 45 cats I
don't my cats to drown I'm okay I'll be
okay and she said I'm going to do the
backstroke back to my house and that's
the kind of spirit everywhere you see
any informational stories you know it's
it's really true all right Gerry thank
you and Fox for everything you all have
been doing you've been putting focus on
this and and we really appreciate it we
really appreciate it certainly in our
job to do that and bring it to the
viewers at home all right lieutenant
governor thank you so much for sharing
these stories you bring us some insight
tonight